[Music]
without good nutrition we're as a
football club and especially in my
position of what you know i have to look
after i'm not responsible for without
good nutritional support you know i'd be
out of a job you know
from my experience
to reach the real top top level you have
to get everything right absolutely
everything our kind of view is when it
comes to anything nutritional it's
really a food first
carbohydrates is obviously the main fuel
we try to periodize our kind of
nutritional intake to the training load
so on those days that are going to be
harder where we have some real tough
sessions that's why we say right you're
going to need to make sure you increase
your carbohydrate intake increase your
protein intake just to match those
levels that you're going to be reaching
and then on our down days where you're
not doing so much in terms of physical
training
that's where we kind of reduce it back
and just so that we can maximize their
their body adaptations you know that
because
footballers tend to like to look good as
well that's that's another side of it
um but you know we don't want them to be
carrying too much kind of adipose tissue
around
you know at breakfast it's more of a
kind of heavier protein kind of base
that they go for and it's more simple
things like some beans or something like
that or they'll have like some granola
or stuff like that on the side of their
kind of protein here but then the day
before games we use a lot of pasta and
rice that's our kind of main thing that
we we push here it's all kind of whole
grain pastas whole game whole grain rice
is the chefs here that are unbelievable
and we kind of see supplements as
anything to boost that
nutritional base that food first base
that we kind of push
it makes stuff a lot simpler you know if
you want to get someone to increase
their protein intake during the day it's
not always that easy to just say right
you know have another meal if they're
going to be flying around doing this
that and the other but being able to
give them a shake or give them you know
like a tub or something like that that
they can then take home with them it's
it makes it really straightforward and
nice and simple for us
this is the first season where we've
been using the kind of gels properly
it's such a good way of getting that
instant hit of carbs in especially when
you're performing so you know during the
game if you can just chuck one on they
can literally just rip one open have it
chuck it back we've had some lads that
sometimes need that little boost towards
the last sort of 20 30 minutes of the
game and and it's been helping them
massively
recovery after games we really try and
hit them straight away the second they
come off you know if you see your sub
being made the first thing they do they
sit down they get given a regal recovery
that's kind of our initial
main player i'd say just because it's
got a great great source of protein in
it great source of carbs that just
starts kicking off that recovery
instantly from coming off a training
pitch or coming off of the game and it's
you know just so easy to get into him
like that you know you have that brief
window after exercise that's so
important to have a traveling chef
ensuring that post game on the bus you
know they're having the best nutrition
possible rather than a quick fix yep
when they go there's your pizza there's
your can of coke you know we're giving
them proper nutrition so they'll have uh
like a team favorite is it's the chili
so our chef makes a mean chili we also
try and push like the kind of nighttime
protein on the labs as well so the
overnight protein we make them up into
little bottles for them
they take them home and have them before
they go to bed
and we try to hit them with like some
antioxidant stuff as well
all these little aspects that are
critical to make sure that again we can
get them out on the picture on a
saturday and a tuesday as regular as we
possibly can
you